6/3 dégagé en 1985
apple lance et une imprimante qui lé
tout révolutionner ça s'appelait la les
orateurs chez lectra blé ça fait
peut-être entamé il ya des gens qui se
rappellent parce que c'était un
changement quand même assez radical
c'est la première imprimante laser pour
le commun des mortels bon elle s'était
pas donné ses imprimantes l'a nommé ça
permettait pour la première fois de
créer de vrais beaux documents parce que
les imprimantes matricielles de l'époque
avec les petits points les pico là ça
faisait un bruit d'enfer c'était pas
terrible mais mettons qu'on pouvait lire
le texte b c'est sûr qu'on est en mesure
d'apprécier la forme vous en rappelez
l'est faut le dire comme c'était et avec
la les orateurs on pouvait donc à la
maison ou à l'école ou dans les clubs
mc je vous dis en passant hors sujet
mais n'accorde ne paraître plus un
papier c'est la dernière édition ont ce
mois-ci oui fin de la parenthèse
on pouvait donc créer des documents qui
se rapprocher à ce qu'on attendait ça
confesse attendant des imprimeries
mais vous savez pour y parvenir la
compagnie apple a dû être inventifs donc
on a combiné une bonne imprimante qui
avait été inventé par cannon
perfectionné par hp aussi de bons
ordinateurs le mcs évidemment et d'un
bon logiciel qui était poste script et
on a mis tous ensemble j'en ai parlé
avec michel dumais qui est chef
blogueurs au journal de montréal
recevait et quelques semaines il nous
racontait sont liés particulier avec la
librairie vous en rappellerez ce qui a
permis aux journaux et aux magazines de
prendre de l'essor ben là les hommes à
deux c'est un peu la suite logique c'est
un outil d'édition pour permettre à
monsieur et madame tout le monde
de publier
là les orateurs avec le mcc luce et le
logiciel pagemaker celle complètement
changé la donne
parce que à peu près tout le monde pour
tout le monde qui avait quand même
plusieurs milliers de dollars à merde
parce que ça coûte est quand même très
cher si 5000 $ voilà exactement plus
l'ordinateur qui était pas donné non
plus longtemps et on achetait le
logiciel ou si on avait entre les mains
un outil qu'on était capable d'exploiter
dans son bureau à la maison à l'apport
l'avait mis un peu ça sympa mme sur les
primes en mai reste que tous ceux ci
comprenait plusieurs technologies
premièrement il y avait l'imprimante
entracte elle qui était fait par la
société canine et il y avait le cerveau
à l'intérieur de cette imprimante et
c'était le langage de description taj
pour ce cru qui avait été fait par une
société nommée à d'obiwi attendant que
l'on connaît par photoshop et donc quel
rôle jouaient ce langage là quand on
essaie de le comprendre comme si on veut
un moyen terme entre l'ordinateur et
cette imprimante
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on pouvait
envoyer des imprimantes laser des pages
complètes qui était un fonds composé de
pixels évidemment ça prenait très peu de
temps pour rendre gorge et l'ordinateur
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas de traiter
autant de pixels souvenons nous que la
puissance informatique d'antin n'étaient
pas la même qu'aujourd'hui or ce que
fait adouber c'est de dire est-ce qu'on
peut prendre cette page et là je
simplifie le missile mais la réduire à
une formule mathématique et lorsque tu
vas lire ce site recompose la page au
fur et à mesure et imprime là et c'est
ce que fait le post lui et c'est ce qui
a complètement révolutionné tout le
domaine de l'infographie
on avait enfin outil qui a permis
l'éclosion de nouvelles races de
travailleurs qui sont les infographistes
mais on a pu voir aussi ou tout début de
tout ceci
des horreurs jusqu'à l'excès n'est pas
un photographe qui veut non on se
rappelle de certaines aux enseignants
peut-être au secondaire qui avait accès
à ces imprimantes le qui avait été
acquise pour les branches en réseau avec
plusieurs mac eux s'en donnait vraiment
à coeur joie avec toutes les polices de
caractère lors alors on pouvait recevoir
une simple lettre qui combinait
plusieurs polices de caractère et qui
combinait ou si plusieurs grèce alors du
grade de l'italique dollar challenge
surligner mais comme l'arrivée de toutes
nouvelles technologies une fois que les
gens se sont approprié cette technologie
là bas on ne put séparer le bon grain de
l'ivraie
la typographie continue d'évoluer et le
prochain klondike c'est la typographie
sur le web et qu'on revoit encore toute
une nouvelle génération de créateurs et
pour vous les origines de ces mêmes
futurs créateurs on peut les rattacher à
cette fameuse trilogie que vous évoquez
absolument tout à fait alors c'est
vraiment là que tout a démarré mais
l'imprimante et le goûter 7000 $ ce
n'est pas gratuit
non c'était et c'est pas tout quand on
regarde toutes les caractéristiques de
cette imprimante la ccac à danser ça à
12 méga hertz qui est vraiment très peu
sur les standards d'aujourd'hui vous
aviez une mémoire embarquée de 512 kg
bail et c'était vraiment pas grand chose
et vous imprégner ce qui était déjà pas
mal
huit pages par minute tout bon conte bis
oui combien ça pesait 60 7 livres 35 kg
donc aujourd'hui la puissance qu'on a
dans des imprimantes qu'on va vous
vendre 100 $ et même pas vous savez on
les voit passer ce qu avec les
imprimantes qu'on fait de l'argent c'est
avec les cartouches d'encre
on avait compris sa au prix où chose et
cartouches d'origine bien ben il ya plus
de puissance là dedans que dans et ça me
fait toujours me posez la question à
quoi vont ressembler les téléphones de
demain les tablettes de demain qui vont
être peut-être comme des papyrus qu'on
va pouvoir rouler est déployée quand on
va en avoir besoin
safetic 5 1 ouais c'est ça a déjà changé
merci beaucoup je vous en prie au revoir